this is a well-worn road
at one end palestinian protesters driven
by years of occupation
what two recent human rights reports
have defined as apartheid
angered and sustained by events in
jerusalem and gaza
at the other the implacable militarized
position
of the israeli forces blocking the way
and more
this is how this day would play out huge
shows of force
pushing back the crowd then young men in
small groups
gradually approaching within tens of
meters of the israeli fortifications
peppering them with rocks and glass
marbles
the israeli tactics varying from
attempting to rush and detain them
to overwhelming them with tear gas and
foul smelling water
to considerably worse so israeli forces
are strengthening their position after
those stone throwers
got pretty close to the checkpoint here
and as you can see on the road just in
front of us
a sniper team has taken up position
later as we reported live there was no
rushing
no show of force simply sniper fire from
a protected position
on unarmed protesters one man fell
injured in front of us
and was taken out by ambulance one among
many here
among dozens across the occupied west
bank
near the illegal settlement of bedell
close to ramallah the gunfire was at one
point going both
ways this is a rare shooting attack on
an israeli military position
during a confrontation a sign of the
seriousness of this current upsurge in
violence
two palestinians were killed here two
israeli soldiers injured
i think our life it needs just only
spark because we are living under this
pressure we are living under
this discrimination regime oppressive
regime
that's that's the the situation
this had been declared a national strike
and a day of rage
observed too in occupied east jerusalem
confrontations
breaking out at damascus gate
and in shakespeare where a long
simmering protest
against forced expulsions of
palestinians has in part fueled this
wider violence
in the southern occupied west bank city
of hebron a palestinian was shot dead by
israeli forces
who said he was carrying a knife a
homemade gun and an explosive device
a brutal day to add to the tally of the
last week
harry fawcett al jazeera bethlehem in
the occupied west bank